now big Nick is really intimidating this
movie did have one scene in the hotel we
just slapping O'Shea around were you
like how comfortable were you because
you slap him a lot like you hit a lot of
people in this movie just everyone you
meet ins maybe like slap him in the face
I just love a lot of people yeah well I
mean that's her big Nick is he's he's a
big bully you know and he's and he's uh
he's a I think these guys they're up
against some of the most brutal people
on the planet and the only way they're
gonna win is a special unit of course
the only way they're gonna get past us
as if they're out brutalized the guys
that we're up against him and to be
honest O'Shea
by the way who is phenomenal he's so
talented but in that room he wouldn't
shut up so in between takes I'd slap his
face too because it was like you need to
be a little bit intimidated you say just
slap him around and then and the scene
slap around I gotta see he took it like
like a trooper because I I beat the [ __ ]
and when other days I know the scenes
and he never never complained man and
they just he knew it was really helping
his performance and killed it by
suspects wearing body armor head shots
only
Popov is saying that the rivalry on set
was was real they would be looking and
we would be thinking what are they
looking at oh so they think they are to
pull this so they are they're doing
police like looking at us and watching
us yeah I was pretty serious I thought I
I didn't know they thought it was fun we
had a lot of fun whether there was an
incredible amount of camera added
between these guys and I know for us
I've never had a bond like that with the
team that I've worked with in a movie I
know and we're still everyday our five
guys still we text each other all day
long I am but there was always here were
they how many bills you fired today
training enough how much you learned
yeah and and you needed that for the
movie you know it worked so beautifully
for you to take to get this tension in
this competition between these two gangs
and it was cool it was conscious of it
we do separation early like before he
was a tactical training we would they
would be trained together so I was like
at the training good I mean I was
holding that one our director would go
and have dinner with an eye nanny
becoming joined oh you know just means
means I am a member of a gang
who worked harder to get into shape for
this for this movie like who worked hard
to look like they were really did that
role their process was tougher preparing
mmm because he put on 25 pounds
yeah I was trying for a while to get get
into get into baking my character was
called big Nick yes can we just take
away the big and I could say I said
you're big Nick there's no data and
started a huge amount of prep why he was
doing that once we got on set though I
think Pablo was just like working the
hardest because he was like in his when
he came in so Jerrod was like the size
he was like and try to catch up